all right when it comes to cleaning
homes and facilities it's important to
protect
after you disinfect our local maid
brigade explains
[Music]
maid brigade is a franchise there's
actually about 80 or 90 of us throughout
the united states there's only one here
in the valley now
that's us we do commercial cleaning but
we also we focus on residential
we do disinfection it's included in all
of our services now
at no additional cost which is a big
deal
commercial service is more buffing
floors and cleaning you know two or
three i'm sorry 20 30 000 square foot
facilities like schools
we don't do things like that but we do
disinfect and protect commercial
facilities
here there's probably maybe 14 15 20
employees going in and out
the difference between home and business
is you don't know where those 14 15 to
20 employees have been that's kind of
where we roll in
and we say you're potentially
multiplying your
exposure by by the hundreds if not the
thousands
when you have 20 30 employees coming and
going because you don't know what
they're doing outside of the facility
so what we offer with disinfection and
protection is
a big step above just cleaning your
facility
the biggest step is protection because
we can come in here and we can disinfect
this facility
until we're blue in the face and that's
great it's disinfected as soon as we
leave
i can test it i can show you but guess
what as soon as it's touched again
it's reinfected that's where and we have
a lot of people say hey how long does it
last
this it doesn't last no disinfectant
lasts beyond
the disinfection time so what the bio
protection does
is it protects this product for up to 90
days the best way to describe it
is it is literally millions of
microscopic barbs
that create an electrostatic field that
basically zap
the little pathogens that might fall on
it or are touched
so if we were to disinfect this and
disinfect this like i said it's fine
but as soon as we sit down again it's
reinfected if we protect it then it's
protected
still you can't just protect you can't
just have somebody come out and be
protected for 90 days and not
take care of the facility again it's
like it's like an electrical field if
that electrical field gets dirty
it can't be properly disinfecting it
can't be properly protected
so this is called an atp meter anything
on this below a 30
is a pass anything above this is a fail
so what we're going to do with this is
basically it's basically just a q-tip
and we're going to schwab where people
would be sitting
[Music]
we're going to get a 15-second countdown
to see where this measures
all right so we're going to spray the
area that we just swabbed
[Music]
so we're going to do the same areas
again
so you see it's at a five so that's
almost perfect we're going to re-schwab
it and see and hopefully
cross our fingers
[Music]
look at that that's actually better than
i thought honestly it usually comes out
in single digits
it went from 99 to zero which means
there's literally not any
bacteria on that surface at all
for more information visit
maidbrigade.com and remember their
special offer
receive a free 90-day protective barrier
with regular service las vegas now we'll
be right back